oui tout de suite antoine cléon en
direct de moscou antoine bonjour alors
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
cette prise de parole du porte parole de
vladimir poutine
nous on vient d'apprendre le porte
parole de vladimir poutine a prévenu
l'agencé de presse russe ria novosti
qu'on lui avait diagnostiqué le
coronavirus et qu'il était actuellement
hospitalisé alors ce n'est pas le
premier homme politique russe être
contaminé le corps d'un virus a été
diagnostiqué entre autres sur le premier
ministre mirail michaud estime le 30
avril
celui ci a été remplacé dans ses
fonctions par le premier vice premier
ministre andri beloussov il ya aussi la
ministre de la culture olga lubineau va
ainsi que le ministre de la construction
vladimir iakounine f à son adjoint
dimitri volkov
la question qu'on peut cependant se
poser est la suivante quel contact le
porte parole at il eu avec le président
ces dernières semaines alors dmitri
peskov a déclaré lui même aujourd'hui à
l'agent stas il n'a pas parlé en
personne au chef de l'état depuis plus
d'un mois
l'avenir poutine se trouve en effet dans
sa résidence de novo ogarevo dans la
banlieue ouest de moscou depuis le début
de la période de confinement à
l'exception de ce saint 19 mai où il
s'est rendu au kremlin pour les
célébrations du 75e anniversaire de la
victoire soviétique sur l'allemagne
nazie
merci beaucoup antoine pour toutes ces
précisions antoine gayraud en direct de
moscou